um I was I was totally shocked and I
don't think I'm worried about scaring
anybody off and and uh if they're not
comfortable with the with the spotlight
or attention then maybe they want to
rethink it but um I'll just I'm gonna go
out and go ahead
a guy reached out who I haven't seen in
20 years thinking about
getting back into the spotlight in some
fashion and his name is Brandon D
Camilla oh and I spoke to him on
the phone
I mean dude he
we had a great talk you know and it's
just been like how long do you guys talk
for I told him uh I taught him by text I
said dude you're the closest thing to an
actual unicorn that I've ever heard of
yeah and he was like ah yeah it's funny
I mean yeah maybe I am kind of a unicorn
and uh you know he uh does he talk to
anybody
I'm not even sure man I'm not we just
talked about like like like what it
might look like for him to uh you know
get back into Show Business
yeah now what does he want to do like
what kind of I told him that I thought
that he like out of anybody is would be
the best suited for for performing live
comedy I think that he could just
absolutely kill it for sure not in
comedy clubs like just if you imagine
just like a chunk of his set being
freestyling you know like like uh just
ranting like you know I mean that's what
like I I really consider that out of
anybody who was ever involved with
jackass
he stands alone as the most talented one
of all of us you can take a bunch of us
and put us together and he's more
talented than that just spontaneity or
like uh and I told him this on on the
phone that his ability to
do nothing
like
remarkable you know nothing physical
nothing like dangerous or or
shocking or scandalous or anything but
but to just do very little and make it
Ultra compelling totally hilarious and
just like spin gold out of nothing like
yeah and he hasn't been active on social
media at all right no but I understand
that he has like
filmed like sketches and stuff that he
just never showed anybody wow just for
No Satisfaction that's sick I think I I
want to say that he confirmed that but I
mean I don't know like
he's not like I told him like I think he
could kill it in in Live Comedy and if
he ever wants to come with me on tour
like we could spend time together we
might be doing an East Coast tour
September maybe he wants to show up to
Boston yeah I think we are in the
comment section if you want to see
Brandon in Boston
that's a great idea and
um and and like he's uh you know I just
told him like the YouTube and creating
content I think he'd just really be well
suited to be a content creator and uh
and he said yeah you know like he wants
to wait I even told him I think it'd be
better to wait until like you've got
sort of uh you know a good amount of
stuff to put out
and then we'll get you know we can get
you on the podcast and promote it yeah I
mean he'd be a great podcast guest dude
I mean we've talked about him it's like
because we're like man like trying to
find these unicorns because like we love
when it's somebody that like it's always
Brandon dico that yeah dico is the top
of that list always for sure yeah he
he'll Crush do you like shopping on
Amazon I do and good news is Stevo's
butt wipes for your butt wall are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude